Patrick Scott is finance editor at the
New York Times and is here to talk to us
this morning about reverse mortgages
welcome to the program sir thank you
first tell us for the sake of this
discussion what exactly is a reverse
mortgage well it's the official term is
a Home Equity Conversion loans so you
mortgage so you know it's not really
going to be simple it's a pretty complex
home loan and maybe the best way to
understand it is in a traditional loan
if you're say young person and you have
a down payment that you then go to a
bank you borrow the rest of it and two
things happen with that loan you have a
monthly mortgage payment and your loan
balance comes down and the ownership
value of the house the equity goes up in
a reverse mortgage the opposite actually
happens where your balance rises and
your equity declines and that's the
difficult thing for people to get their
heads around so in order to get one of
these you have to be 62 years or older
you generally have to own the home or
have substantial equity in the home but
you don't have a monthly mortgage
payment you still are responsible though
for the property taxes maintenance and
insurance payments which can be
considerable but you can defer the
payment of the loan until you move out
or the borrower dies and we have an
example of a notice of eligibility that
sent out by one of the companies that
offer these reverse mortgages and it has
it says get rid of your mortgage payment
now no credit or income requirements the
US government has approved a mortgage
stimulus package for homeowners 62 years
of age or older as a result of the
Housing and policy Recovery Act of 2011
this program has already helped
thousands of senior seniors like
yourself save their home these
applications these pitches seem very
tempting
someone who may be getting on in age and
and needs money to make it from day to
day correct yeah there's definitely
risks all through the process here you
know there are circumstances in which
these can work for seniors but the risks
start with what you read there that's
the advertising can be misleading they
can be promoting you know take your
dream vacation where you should only be
taking these loans out if you really
need the money and we'll get into that
in in detail but there's also they
require counseling but often that
counseling is ineffective it can be
pretty quick it can be over the phone
and it's not giving the seniors the
information that they truly need to make
an informed decision mm-hmm and also
when you take the money out there's also
the the prospect that they can be
targeted the seniors for fraudsters in
all sorts of different complex ways that
they take the money investing the money
and the seniors may lose a lot of that
money through that process the other big
risks for this of course are that you
still have to pay the property taxes and
the insurance and the maintenance and if
you can't keep up with those payments
then you're in default and then you can
lose your home so there's a lot of
things that you really have to be
careful about before you enter into
these loans Patrick Scott in the New
York Times what type of banks offer
these reverse mortgages and what's the
incentive beyond dis profit for these
banks to do these kind of mortgages well
there's a lot of lenders who offer them
it's interesting that the big banks like
Bank of America and Wells Fargo last
year got out of making these loans those
are the biggest companies in terms of
mortgages in the United States and they
got out of it in part because property
values were declining it was hard to
value the you know the the property
itself and it was very unclear of the
ability of these senior citizens to pay
the loans and they were also count
reverse
there were some stories that were out
there and reports in the media about how
people were losing their homes at
increasing rates so those banks got out
of it it's smaller mortgage lenders that
are doing it now the primary incentive
for them is that they are making money
on the front end with the fees that they
get they can be considerable they're
higher than typical mortgage fees but
it's also the interest rates that they
they the interest you're paying on this
loan increases through the life of the
loan so the banks are going to make it
through that interest payment we're
talking with Patrick Scott finance
editor at The New York Times about
reverse mortgages and we'd like for the
audience to get involved in the
conversation the numbers to zero to five
eight five thirty eight eighty one for
Republicans Democrats to zero to five
eight five thirty eight eighty
independents to zero to five eight five
thirty eight eighty two we'll also take
your messages via social media Twitter
Facebook and email our first call for
Patrick Scott comes from James in Bay
City Michigan on our line for
Republicans James you're on the
Washington journal go ahead good morning
good morning I like to ask a couple of
short questions I understand if you have
no children at all that it would be a
good deal on the other hand what is the
downsides of this thing at all
I'm course I'm I'm 90 years old so I
don't know if I'd be a great dealer to
thank you well the first thing that
people should think about is whether
they really need to have this money if
you need it to stay in the home and you
have no other assets or no other way to
borrow money then you should look into
you can look into a reverse reverse
mortgage you can the thing you have to
be careful of is that say for instance
if you have a property that's valued at
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
then if you're younger say sixty-five
you could maybe get a loan of like a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars on
that because they don't give you
the full value of the home in the loan
they give you you know a portion of that
but it goes up as you're older so if
you're 90 years old and you have that
$250,000 house you can get close to
$200,000 on that house the question is
what are you going to do with that lump
sum of money and if there's another 10
years that a person lives then you can
be adding you know 80 or more thousand
dollars to that loan so you're gonna
know about $300,000 when the home has to
be sold so there's you know through the
AARP through the Federal Trade
Commission and through the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau there's a
lot of information in queue as for when
this is appropriate and when it's not
next up is Alexis in Herndon Virginia
alexis is on our line for democrats go
ahead you're on the Washington journal
turn down your television set okay I
want no I want you to mute your
television okay what's your caller
what's your question or comment for
Patrick Scott in the New York Times I
try to apply for all the programs that
are out there but not succeed my husband
lost his job and I still have to pay
three thousand dollars ten months only
3,000 per month I'm unable even to buy
food for my children what can I do
Alexis are you over 60 are you 62 years
or older
no I'm 40 so then she wouldn't qualify
for a reverse mortgage switching no not
for a reverse mortgage because you have
to be 62 or older but it sounds like
that the caller would be a candidate
possibly for a modification
and that would mean that it would either
reduce the amount of money overall owed
on the home if the bank would be willing
to do that or lower the monthly payments
by reducing the interest rate oftentimes
though the value of the loan say if you
owe $300,000 on that house and you can't
make payments now or you have to make
reduce payments they'll tack that down
to the end of the loan so the loan is
going to be bigger you have to when
you're ever in that situation you have
to go directly to your lender first off
but there's also help that you can get
through counselors through the federal
government who can help you you
shouldn't pay any sort of fees for a
counselor to help you modify your
mortgage or to restructure your mortgage
so you mortgage so you could afford your
payment's that should be a free service
that the federal government provides and
you can find that out from your lender
as well our next call for Patrick Scott
of the New York Times comes from Ronnie
Ronnie lives in Pedro Ohio and is on our
independence line go ahead yes the
question I have you sit on the reverse
mortgage that you get the love song I'm
the several people that have done it and
they only get a monthly payment back
they're not getting a lot song right
there's a few ways and this is the part
of the complexity of it there's a few
ways that you can get the money so you
can take out the lump sum in that
example that I gave you before if you're
like 65 and you have a $250,000 house
you can get a lump sum of a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars say but you can
also choose to take you know half of it
in a lump sum and the other half in like
a line of credit that can either be
tapped when you need it or it could be a
monthly stream of income that would be
provided over a certain amount of time
or over the time that you actually live
so there's a lot of different ways that
you can access the money generally it's
the lump sum it's a fixed interest rate
or you can get a variable or adjust
thing rate that is more of a line of
credit so basically the difference
between refinancing the loan on your
house or the mortgage on your house and
taking a reverse mortgage is that with
the refinancing you still continue to
make monthly payments with the with the
reverse mortgage you just get the lump
sum and you don't have to make payments
pretty much it's like for refinancing
you're just now lowering the monthly
payments that you're making and in a
reverse mortgage right so you're getting
you're actually unlocking the money that
is the equity in the house and you're
getting to use that now as opposed to
what would happen as you you know you
may want to downsize you may be a
widower and have a four-bedroom house
and you you don't really need all that
space so you could sell that house now
and then move into a smaller place so
you're unlocking the value of the house
that way directly as opposed to entering
into this reverse mortgage contract what
would be the difference between a
reverse mortgage and a opening up a home
equity line of credit well the home
equity line of credit you don't have to
take the money in you don't have to you
know you don't have the temptation to
spend it if you're taking the lump sum
with a reverse mortgage you take that
money the lump sum one hundred and
thirty thousand dollars in that example
but then you're actually having to
through the interest increase the value
of that or the loan balance so you could
add $80,000 in ten years on it so in
that case line of credit you only take
it when you need it but with this you're
actually rising the loan balance our
next call for Patrick Scott of the New
York Times comes from Dale in Amarillo
Texas Dale's on our line for Republicans
go ahead Dale oh I watch c-span for
decades and this is the first time I've
called you so I'm glad to do that enjoy
your show happy to have you on I've just
noticed a lot of colors on your show on
the Republican line seem to be have
democratic and ideas and views so that
was interesting but I have
first mortgage that I took out in 2008
and it's allowed me to retire when I
would not have been able to do so until
2020 so my question is I had a problem
with the mortgage company about adhering
to the terms of the contract and I could
not afford an attorney so who would I go
to or is there a government agency that
I can go to when I have a problem like
that Dell before you go can I ask you
what was the the amount of your loan I
think it was after the it was about
forty five hundred dollars worth of fees
that were added in so the amount of the
loan ended up being eighty five the
equity in my home was about ninety or
something like that
but so when the fees were added in I
think it's about eighty five thousand
all right thanks for your call Patrick
Scott the best place that you can go to
is a when the dodd-frank financial
regulation law was created in 2010 it
transferred the responsibility for
rulemaking regulations of mortgages to
that Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau so what they're doing is that
they're looking for out for consumers
and whether there's deceptive or unfair
or abusive practices they have a hotline
there and they take complaints about
that and they can also help you get
directed to legal help that can be
provided in counseling can be provided
at no cost the counseling on these loans
you should have had counseling before
you took out this loan and they
typically cost like one hundred and
twenty-five dollars but they're supposed
to provide that for free as well if you
can't afford it
the CFPB the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau also also released a
report to Congress on reverse mortgages
that came out earlier this summer
On June 28 2012 and you can
find that at the CFPB website that'll
give you more information as well
regarding reverse mortgages and
Congress's involvement as well Pat is
our next caller from Baytown Texas on
our line for Democrats you're on the
Washington journal Pat go ahead
yes sir I'm just calling is this a scam
for the banks to buy houses at low
prices and I hang up and listen for your
answer
thank you well it's an interesting
question there is a group in California
and there are advocates for nursing home
reforms and there's a lawyer with that
group named Prescott Cole one of his
concerns is that it's particularly the
maintenance cost on these loans so you
need to make sure that you have money to
keep this property up and that's part of
the covenants of the loan so you you
know if it needs a new roof in seven
years or a paint job or whatever it
could be very expensive and his you know
suspicion is is that in five to ten
years when the housing market starts to
correct that there'll be more of these
agents going out and looking at the
condition of these properties in
determining that they're in need of
maintenance and when people can't afford
them the banks will then take over those
properties and sell them for a profit
and these people will be out of their
homes that's not the intention of the
banks they're of course trying to make
money but also trying to find a way
where people can unlock the value of
their home now when they really need it
as long as they fully understand the
ramifications of these loans next up is
Kathy in Canton Massachusetts Kathy's on
our line for independence go ahead Kathy
I'd like to know what is going to happen
to all the people that could not get any
help from either the president's program
or the lender as much as they tried and
they ended up walking away from their
houses
thank you this is Scott well in those
cases that when people walked away from
their homes that was something that
people in in the mortgage market really
had not seen because those homes are
underwater and that's when you owe more
than the value of the house and it just
doesn't make sense for people to
continue to pay their mortgages they
think but it sort of up ends this whole
rule of law and in honoring contracts
where if you can afford it you and have
a job and you have a commitment to make
that payment you're obligated to make
that payment when the interest rates
come down as they have now - like
historic lows at 3.5% you can refinance
so it's cheaper for you to stay in that
home but if there was if you really say
if you lost your job or if you had a
difficulty with medical expenses and you
could no longer afford your mortgage and
say you even modified it with the bank
and it lowered your interest pay
payments or even reduce the principal of
the loan and you still can't pay the
mortgage the newly restructured mortgage
then there are a number of people who
have no recourse except they can't get
another modification and they lose their
home and that's in part I mean the
foreclosure rate is still high in
America it had been skyrocketing in many
communities and there's still a glut of
homes out there that are foreclosed
homes on the market that are still
keeping property values low so that is
just a problem in the housing market in
the economy that is going to take years
to work through we're talking with
Patrick Scott from New York City this
morning he is a finance editor with the
New York Times and he's talking to us
about the ins and outs of reverse
mortgages including the risks involved
in government oversight of the industry
in an article that was written last week
Patrick Scott by Jessica silver
Greenberg with the
a risky lifeline for the elderly is
costing some their homes
she writes as the vast baby boomer
generation heads for retirement and many
more seniors grapple with dwindling
savings the newly minted Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau is working
on new rules that could mean better
disclosure for consumers and stricter
supervision of lenders more than seven
hundred and seventy-five thousand of
such loans are outstanding according to
the federal government with baby boomers
retiring and greater and greater numbers
and if they are the largest consumers of
these reverse mortgages is there a
potential for a subprime disaster to
sort of repeat itself the way we saw
earlier in this decade with people who
took out home loans that really couldn't
afford them
there's definitely concerns and there
are risks and there were new abuses that
Jessica had documented disaster would
probably be a strong word on this
because still of the people who were
eligible for these loans two to three
percent of the of them are tapping their
his reverse mortgages they had really
spiked you know before the financial
crisis in 2007 and 2006 it was over a
hundred thousand a year now it's down to
around seventy thousand but the concern
is is baby boomers are looking as their
medical costs increase and they're
looking for ways that they can have more
money in retirement that they'll be
taking more of these loans and what the
report that the CFPB put out showed a
couple of trends and more of them like
seventy percent are taking the lump sums
and that's kind of risky because even
now if you take that lump sum and you
put it in a money market account for
example you're making practically
nothing on the interest but your
interest rate might be four or five
percent so your
not using that money wisely and also
they were finding that people are
younger starting to take out these loans
and so the risk is that you have a
greater risk of foreclosure because you
can run out of the money and not be able
to afford to stay in the house so but
it's a question of like how widespread
this is going to be part of part of the
issue is is that the banks the private
loans that were being made in the
subprime days when there were all sorts
of loose lending practices they were
also packaged and sold to investors
through bonds that's not occurring now
with these so that helps to decrease the
contagion of products like these that
could go bad now according to the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
these reverse mortgages are insured by
the Federal Housing Administration and
if the loan exceeds the value of the
home at repayment then FHA covers the
balance so if the homeowner gets
themselves into a situation where they
can't repay the loan and they foreclose
who takes ownership of the house well
the bank owns the house and a
foreclosure if there is a default on the
loan for whatever reason you're paying
for the mortgage insurance for the FHA
so the consumer is actually paying for
that so it's not like the government is
going to be stuck with a whole bunch of
houses now I mean the government has a
lot of houses now the you know the GSE
is those housing finance corporations
have a lot of houses now it'll typically
be that the bank would then take
ownership of this home and then they'll
either put it on the market or they'll
hold it in their inventory because they
may not want to have like a glut of
additional homes on the market back to
the phone's valerie is calling from
archibald pennsylvania on our line for
republicans you're our next caller on
the Washington journal Valerie you're
talking with Patrick Scott of the New
York Times go ahead
yes mr. Scott I wonder if you could
comment on this situation I have an
acquaintance who has a house it's fully
paid for she is age 62 and she is
disabled she's having a lot of trouble
maintaining the expenses of the home
however my question for you is
she is also eligible for numerous social
programs particularly medical medically
related for her disability and I wonder
does the income that you generate by
undertaking a reverse mortgage does that
become reportable income how does it
impact on your eligibility for social
programs thank you so much well it's
generally not taxed that income but it
then may affect it we just have to it
would depend on the program and then the
actual amount of money that you have as
assets can actually reflect on your
eligibility perhaps but you would have
to check with that program that I guess
the question would be for that person of
whether you know if they're struggling
with the cost already would this
actually give them enough money to be
able to meet those costs over the life
of the loan and one of the things that
the the consumer and elderly advocates
talk about is that it's really important
for people to sit down with their say
their parents now and adult children and
just talk about finances and have those
difficult conversations which people
often don't and really establish do you
really need this money and is there any
other way that you can get this money or
does it have to be through a reverse
mortgage you know this some advocates
look at peer to peer lending where
you're actually borrowing from your
children if you need you know $500 a
month that you're getting that from your
your offspring and then when the time
comes to sell that home they would
inherit that but they
have they get their repayment from what
they had loaned you and then still the
siblings could carve up the asset and
still have some sort of inheritance but
it's important for people to sit down
and have these conversations now next up
is John on our line for Republicans
calling from White Plains this morning
go ahead John
good morning mr. Scott my question
follows what Rob already asked about
when someone takes a monthly income on a
reverse mortgage and they're in a
desperate situation and relatively early
on with say six months or so they cannot
keep up with the property tax the
insurance and the maintenance and then
you just said well then the bank owns a
home has it been your experience where
predatory lending due to insufficient
counsel actually had significant impact
with a large number of people that
generally not you know very effective
when when it's that desperate and early
on they lose a home because they the
bank doesn't have much equity either at
that point I was just interested in what
you had to say about that Thanks
yeah I mean that's the big risk
particularly because in some
circumstances they've found that the
subprime predatory mortgage brokers or
originators moved from that space and
now they're into the reverse mortgage
space too
so they're you know people are really
worried about that where they're calling
up people and saying hey you need you
know repairs on your house a new roof or
whatever you don't have to pay for that
because we can actually do this reverse
mortgage cover all your maintenance cost
you in it won't cost you anything and
you might even get some money back and
there's predatory lenders out there now
who are actually taking that money that
they would get from say a lump sum or
even a monthly installment and the
homeowner is not seeing any of that and
the work may not even get done on the
house so there's definitely concerns out
there and that's where the mortgage
lenders Association and the CFPB are
trying to make sure that they understand
you know who is making these loans how
they're advertising and that people
fully understand the ability of the
person to make those payments next up is
can in Glendale Arizona on our line for
independence Glen you're on the
Washington journal can I'm sorry yes
good good morning mr. Scott and the host
for Washington journal I would like to
find out that a person at age 62 that
person having disabilities related to
diabetes neuropathy you know those that
particular illness does start to get
worse not better generally unless they
gain themselves in a treatment program
such as exercise and so forth my
question is a lot of Quicken Loans a lot
of other companies the ones that
advertise with actors generally these
companies are offering the reverse
mortgages not really even paying any
type of attention to the word reverse
now having a very good knowledge of
banking because I've graduated that was
my major in college the banking program
at a junior college level and being a
construction for almost 25 years mainly
commercial that believe me commercial is
no different than residential a lot of
homes that people and in four years they
turn to either get refinance at the
later age such as myself 63 and
sometimes it's very difficult because of
the three C's the credit capacity
collateral the rules of trying to get a
refinance they're difficult because the
income is usually deficient and the the
collateral is
in terms of dec wa t and then of credit
you know at the age of 63 you've been
through quite a bit of life where your
credit isn't the greatest unless you've
had no problems throughout your life
with regards to payment history and so
forth 10 I have to leave it there we're
sort of running out of time Patrick
Scott can you address Ken's concerns
yeah I mean the bottom line is that
these loans because they're not the
traditional loans they don't depend
really on you having income it's
dependent on the equity that you have in
your house so you know if you're 62 you
can borrow
like I think it's 56 percent of the
value of the home
so you just the bank wants to make sure
that you have you know your collateral
is the equity that you have in the house
and that's what they're gonna base on
whether they get their money back
whether they can you know turn that
property for a profit and make sure that
they get their money back so you have to
be careful about that just understanding
is that the best use of the equity that
you have in your home what if any
concerns are have been generated in
Congress right now about the
administration of these reverse
mortgages there any investigations or
any anything that that Congress is
looking into well primarily but through
the dodd-frank law they have transferred
that to this CFPB that Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau and they
required them to come up with this
report so Congress gets the report and
now they are looking to the bureau to
develop new rules and regulations where
necessary so they've pretty much put it
in the court of the of the bureau our
last call for Patrick Scott comes from
Olga in Houston Texas on our line for
Republicans go ahead Olga yes good
morning
my question is can they garnish any of
your reverse mortgage funds for default
student loans or maybe unpaid medical
bills can they require you to get money
out of a reverse mortgage if you have
one if you have medical expenses that
you can't pay Patrick Scott of the New
York Times go ahead right that's an
excellent question and that's definitely
something that the counselors who are
supposed to be trained in all aspects of
these loans would be able to advise
someone on because you can't take these
loans out really without having
counseling but that's a good question I
don't know the answer to it exactly
whether if there is I mean if there's a
lien on the house then you're not going
to be able to tap into that and there's
going to be issues with not being able
to get that loan in the first place so
but if there's other outstanding debts
that maybe are still in effect you would
not put it past any sort of institution
that might have sold it off to a debt
collection collection agency or who is
looking to try and get their arrears
collected put it past them to try and
come after you if all of a sudden you
have money so that's definitely
something as in all these cases it's to
make sure that you understand all of the
aspects of these loans and the
ramifications because they are complex
and understand it fully like questions
like that before you go into it we've
been talking with Patrick Scott finance
editor at The New York Times about
reverse mortgages thank you very much
for being on the Washington journal this
morning great thank you